no to war was the final statement
broadcast on russia's last independent
tv channel tv reign
all its employees walked out in protest
against what they see as severe
government censorship
and in its final seconds on air it
showed this
[Music]
a nod to russian history
the swan lake ballet performance was
broadcast on state tv in the soviet era
either at times of political crises or
after the death of a leader
it was famously shown in 1991 during the
attempted coup that contributed to the
end of the soviet union for many here
it's now become a symbol of broken
dreams and political instability
[Applause]
tv reign was founded in 2010 with the
motto talk about important things with
those who are important to us
now after the start of russia's
so-called special military operation in
ukraine
this channel is no longer able to
continue because of government
interference
on friday both houses of parliament
passed the new law aimed at targeting
media outlets that are accused of
spreading fake information
it is now a criminal offense to spread
what the government considers
misinformation about its military
a crime which could land a journalist in
prison for up to 15 years
members of the russian government
believe this is crucial in protecting
the armed forces
taking into account the situation that
is happening in the media space all
those id companies starting from
instagram let's say and others are
located in the united states of america
it is understandable that they are used
as weapons they are bringing hatred and
lies we must counter it and protect our
armed forces
the hammer of state sensors have also
targeted one of the most well-known
radio stations in the country echo of
moscow took to the airwaves in august of
1990 shortly before the fall of the
soviet union the following year
its motto all significant points of view
about events should be presented no
longer appears to apply to journalists
in russia
tatiana felgengauer was a journalist
working at both tv reign and echo of
moscow
it's terrible it's a catastrophe a true
catastrophe an absolutely terrific
mistake by vladimir putin who decided to
plunge russia into this i will say it
again catastrophe and i'm terribly
scared both for my country and for
ukraine i'm terribly ashamed in front of
ukrainians it's incredible for me to
realize that the president of my country
started this and i'm afraid that there's
nothing good ahead for my country and
for me as a citizen
russia's independent media are slowly
disappearing accused of falsely
depicting the war in ukraine novaya
gazetta is one of the last independent
newspapers here and its editor dmitry
muratov who shared the nobel peace prize
last year says his paper could be on the
verge of shutting down
that's because according to him anything
that's not propaganda is being
eliminated
dorsal jabari al jazeera moscow